Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today we'll be answering the question
how similar our German and Dutch,
wait,
what were those two languages again?
German Deutsche,
Dutch Nadir loans.
Deutsche.
Isn't it strange that English speakers
called the language of the Netherlands
and Flanders Dutch while German speakers
called their own language?
Deutsche,
why is that?
It's because there's a connection
between Dutch and German.
Both are Germanic.
The English word Dutch used to refer to
continental Germanic peoples in general,
but then came to refer to only the
people of the Netherlands because of
greater contact and rivalry with them.
In particular,
the English word comes from the Middle
Dutch word do teach and in modern Dutch
Dutch,
which means German,
and this is a cognate of the German
word,
Deutsche.
And with that we've already begun
comparing the two languages.
In Dutch they say Dutch and in German
they say Deutsche.
Germanic and Dutch are both members of
the West Germanic branch of the Germanic
language family,
both developed from the same root,
the same ancestor language,
Pro Germanic,
which developed into Western,
eastern and northern dialect groups.
The Western dialects are the ancestors
of Dutch and German and the other west
Germanic languages.
One thing we have to keep in mind when
comparing Dutch and German is that there
are many dialects of Dutch and there are
many dialects of German and in northern
Germany and parts of Netherlands,
there are dialects that arguably form
another language,
low German or low Saxon,
and there's another regional language
called Frisian,
but speakers of all of these dialects
learn either standard Dutch or standard
German depending on which country they
live in.
So there may be cases when German and
Dutch speakers understand each other
more easily when their dialects are
closer to each other,
but there are other situations in which
their dialects are further apart and it
would be easiest to communicate in the
standard languages.
In this video,
I'll focus on standard Dutch and
standard German vocabulary.
Dutch and German share a large amount of
cognitive vocabulary.
According to one source I've seen their
lexical similarity is around 84% which
is slightly lower than Spanish and
Italian or Spanish and Portuguese.
84% lexical similarity doesn't mean that
84% of the words are exactly the same.
It means that they are cognates.
They come from a common origin,
but they may have a different form or be
pronounced differently.
Some examples,
the word for glass in German and in
Dutch plus the word for water in German
and in Dutch.
That or the word for dog,
hence the word for brother Buddha,
Buddha,
but this here is actually an archaic
form of the word.
The modern form of the word is the word
for sister Smith Zoster.
This is also an archaic form.
The modern form is just,
and here are a couple of phrases.
Good Morning Guten Morgen who?
Morgan,
good day or good afternoon.
Guten tag.
Who did?
Ah,
it's sunny,
it's sunny.
Who dish.
There are a lot of cognates like that,
but there are false cognates as well.
In Dutch.
J Means C and Mir means lake in German.
Z means lake and mia mean C,
but there's actually a bit more to it
than that.
There's actually a masculine word,
desi meaning lake and a feminine word.
Dizzy meaning see in Dutch Leeson means
to lie as an to tell a lie in German
leagon means to lie as in to lie down on
a bed.
For example,
in Dutch listen means to lie on
something like a bed in German.
Logan means to tell a lie.
In Dutch,
painless means painful,
but in German normally means
embarrassing.
In Dutch [inaudible] mean it's be
allowed to and in German means to like,
but hold on a second.
The Dutch word can also be used with the
meaning to like specifically when you
like a person,
the German word is used more generally
for people or things you like.
So even though a lot of cognates may be
obvious or easy to decipher,
assuming that they mean the same thing
might cause some confusion.
Pronunciation,
I'm sure you noticed that most of those
cognate words sounded a little different
and some of them sounded quite
different.
One of the biggest differences between
Dutch and German is the different sounds
in either language and how these results
in cognate words that sound different.
Some of the differences between Dutch
and German are a result of the high
German consonant shift which took place
in the few hundred years leading up to
the ninth century.
German descends from dialects that were
affected by these changes.
While Dutch descends from dialects that
were not affected by these changes
because of the shift,
voiceless stops to and come in.
Dutch tend to be fricatives for sup and
in German cognates when between vowels
or after a vowel at the end of a word
for example,
the words meaning ship in Dutch skip and
in German shoes and the words meaning
water in Dutch that are and in German
and the Pronoun meaning I in Dutch Ig
and in German these same voiceless stops
became Africans for sub or at the
beginning of a word or if they were
doubled consonants or if they came after
an l or our sound.
For example,
the words for apple in Dutch fucking and
in German and the words meaning heart in
Dutch hearts and in German.
The third challenge cup changing to cut
occurred only an upper German dialect
and not in standard German.
Another shift also took place in the
voice stops,
Buh Duh and gum which became voiceless
and cook,
but with only the dump to touch shift
taking place in standard German.
The other changes only took place in
upper German dialects.
For example,
the word for day in Dutch and in German
tack.
Remember before when I said that certain
German speakers would have an easier
time understanding Dutch because of
their dialects?
Well,
that's especially true for low German
dialects because like Dutch,
they didn't undergo this hydromatic
consonant shift.
There was another sound change that
affected high German but also low German
and Dutch thumb and the became duck.
This explains why Germans still has a
Duh sound even though there was an
earlier shift from Dakota.
There are also other sound differences
that are not a result of the hydromatic
consonant shift.
Notice the different g sounds in the
word for God in Dutch holds and in
German the German is more or less like
the English good.
That Dutch sound varies depending on the
region,
but as a villa or uvular fricative,
you may have also noticed that the wwe
sounded different in the words for
water,
so let's hear those again.
In Dutch Vassar and in German,
the German sound is similar to the v
sound.
In English,
the Dutch W is pronounced differently in
the beginning or in the middle of the
word.
It's sort of between a va and the what
sounds,
but at the end of a word,
after a vowel,
it's a glide.
Just like w in English,
our sounds are sounds very quite a lot
in either language,
depending on where the speakers from,
but they're often different in either
language.
For example,
the word for year in Dutch and in
German.
Yeah,
in the Dutch word.
The final r sounds like a retroflex
approximate raw,
like in some varieties of English,
but other speakers say it as a trilled
are and when it's not at the end of the
word,
the trilled are,
is more consistently used,
especially in northern areas and in the
German word,
the Rs pronounced as a vowel.
It's also pronounced as a vowel.
In some other contexts like between
vowels or after a long vowel and before
another consonant.
In other contexts,
it's more like a voice to uvular,
fricative,
ah,
at least in a standard accent of
Germany.
Here's another example using the words
meaning rough in Dutch.
Here you can clearly hear the trilled
are and in German some consonants are
spelled the same but sound different.
Some are spelled differently and sound
different and others are spelled
differently but sounded the same.
One example is that Czi is spelled as
zed in Dutch,
but as s in German,
German s is also pronounced,
so at the end of a word or after
consonants other than l and nasals,
two words we saw earlier are German and
Dutch Zuma.
There are many differences in vowels as
well.
Some are spelled differently,
but sound basically the same like the
words meaning year that we saw a minute
ago.
Let's hear those again and focus on the
vowel in Dutch and in German.
Yeah,
notice that the vowel is spelled
differently.
Another example,
the words meaning good in Dutch hoots
and in German.
There were also a lot of pairs of
cognates in which the vowel sounds have
become different and that is reflected
in their spelling.
For example,
their words for dream in Dutch and in
German town along o vowel in Dutch often
corresponds with this diphthong in
German the words meaning body but to
cognate with the English word life in
Dutch lace and in German.
These diphthongs often correspond with
each other.
Another similar example is the word for
bite in Dutch Bayton and in German Bison
also notice this German letter that
represents the sound sub after long
vowels or diphthongs as opposed to a
double s after short vowels.
This orthographic symbols,
it doesn't exist in Dutch,
in Dutch,
so is always represented by a single s
and it's worth noting that this symbol
is not used in Swiss standard German
either.
They always write it as a double s
grammar.
There are some important similarities
and some important differences between
the grammar of the two languages.
One difference is their use of
grammatical gender.
German has three genders,
masculine,
feminine and Neuter,
which applied to announce their articles
and adjectives that modify them.
Dutch historically had the same three
genders,
but in practice,
in modern Dutch,
masculine and feminine essentially form
a single common gender.
So the only grammatical distinction is
between common gender and neuter.
And related to that,
German has three definite articles.
While duck has two and for indefinite
articles,
German has just two and Dutch has just
won.
Another difference is that German has
nauman cases,
different forms of nouns depending on
their function in the sentence.
The four cases in German are nominative,
genitive Datas,
and accusative.
Dutch used to have now in cases,
but they fell out of use in the spoken
language and in the 1940s they were
dropped from the standard language.
Now they appear and some older idioms,
but that's about it.
That lack of noun cases arguably makes
Dutch easier to learn than German,
at least in that particular way.
Oh,
and remember a minute ago when I said
that German has three definite articles.
Well,
it's actually not that simple.
Each definite article has some
variations depending on the announced
case.
Let's look at the nominative and
accusative cases.
Just to illustrate these sentences mean
the red fish is expensive in German and
in Dutch,
Dutch road as this is dear.
As you can see,
the sentences can be translated word for
word from English.
The function of the phrases meaning the
red fish is nominative because the
subject of either sentence,
these sentences mean I like the red
fish.
In German
marketing [inaudible]
and in Dutch it often the low disease
here at the phrases meaning the red fish
are the direct object,
which means their function is
accusative.
You can see that in Dutch the noun
phrase stays the same despite its
accusative function in the sentence,
but in German the accusative form is
different then.
Now that self doesn't have a special
ending that's different depending on the
gender and the case,
but the definite article changes and the
adjective has a special ending.
When you consider the different case
forms for nouns,
articles and adjectives,
there are a lot of possible
combinations.
These are for definite noun phrases and
these are for indefinite noun phrases.
Learning the different cases.
Forms has a challenge for learners of
German,
but if you learn Dutch,
you don't have to memorize all those
different forms and endings which affect
nouns,
adjectives,
articles,
and possessives,
et cetera.
Word order.
In the sentence we just saw the word
order was essentially the same in both
languages and both were the same as an
English.
In the following sentences,
they share the same syntax,
but they're different from English.
These sentences mean I can play the
piano very well in German
can zack,
good,
Claudia speedin and in Dutch
ECOM,
who's piano spelling word for word?
Both sentences are I can.
Very good piano play in both sentences.
The conjugated verb and auxiliary verb
comes second after the subject.
Both languages feature Vitu word order
and in both languages the unconjugated
verb moves to the end for clarity.
Let's simplify those previous sentences
by removing the adverb phrase,
so now they mean I can play the piano.
In German he can clavio spillman
and in Dutch it come pianos Balan.
Now let's add something so that they
mean,
I want to be able to play the piano
in German.
[inaudible] via [inaudible]
word for word.
It's,
I want piano play,
be able to,
and in Dutch it Kerrville,
piano,
cleanness,
spillane word for word.
It's I want piano be able to play in
Dutch.
When another auxiliary verbus added this
auxiliary verb,
[inaudible] gets moved back.
But the main lexical verb is still at
the end.
In German,
the equivalent auxiliary verb gets moved
to the end.
After the lexical verb,
the same difference occurs in relative
clauses.
These sentences mean he knows that I can
play the piano
in German advice.
Does he clubish Billington
word for word,
it's he knows that I piano play Ken and
in Dutch hiv-aids don't take piano
concert and word for word eds.
He knows that I piano Ken play.
So while the word order is generally
similar,
there are some differences in the
details like that.
Let's look at one more final sentence
and see what we find.
Let's compare two.
Meaning if I had enough money,
I'd buy a car first in Dutch,
Joelton,
Alto,
copen word for word.
It's if I enough money,
had wood I uh,
car by next in German.
Verdad Ishmael,
how to them word for word.
It's if I enough money,
had wood I myself a car by.
These are both conditional sentences
with two clauses,
an if clause and the main clause.
First.
You might notice that even though I said
both languages have Vitu word order,
neither of these sentences seem to have
verbs in the second position.
In the first clause,
the verb comes last and in the second
clause the verb comes first.
Well this here is the main clause or
independent clause.
So we should focus on this when thinking
about Vitu word order.
If this clause alone where the entire
sentence than the subject would come
first and the verb would come second,
making it Vitu word order.
This here is the dependent clause.
In other words,
it's not a sentence by itself.
It only adds information to the main
clause.
So this whole dependent clause occupies
the first position and in the main
clause,
the verb moves before the subject to
occupy second position,
making it Vitu word order first.
We can see that the words for if are
different.
Then we have the slightly different
cognates meaning I hear we have cognate
words,
meaning enough.
Notice that the vowel sound the same but
are spelled differently and notice that
the letter g looks the same but sounds
different in Dutch.
The g sounds are Uvula fricatives ha.
Next we have the cognate words for
money.
The next word is an important one in
Dutch.
This if clause simply has the past tense
form of the verb,
heaven meaning to have in German.
However,
this is a subjunctive verb form
something that Dutch doesn't have.
Subjunctive forms are used to express
hypothetical situations,
express doubt or express something you
wish were true.
Next we see the auxiliary verbs in the
main clause which both translate as
would the German word is for past
subjunctive form of that in and the
Dutch word is the past tense of Xulane,
which by the way is a cognate of the
English word Shell.
Notice that in German there's an extra
word here.
This word is a reflexive pronoun which
is used to show that you are buying
something for yourself.
This is the data form of the first
person singular pronoun.
This is not completely necessary but as
commonly used in this context.
In Standard Dutch,
the reflexive pronoun is not used here.
Next we have the indefinite articles
which are cognates.
The German one though is the nuder
accusative form.
While in Dutch there's only one form of
the indefinite article.
Next,
the word for car is similar.
The Dutch word is in the common gender.
In other words,
historically masculine or feminine.
The German word is neuter gender and in
the accusative form,
but this form takes no special ending to
distinguish it for some genders and it
does and for others it doesn't.
Finally,
we see the word for by Copeland in Dutch
Kalfen in German,
the German consonant sound foot as a
result of the hydromatic consonant shift
that we talked about earlier and also
notice the different vowel sound.
There are a lot of similarities between
those two sentences we just looked at,
but there are also a lot of differences,
probably enough for you to realize that
to a large extent,
German and Dutch are not mutually
intelligible.
For people who haven't been exposed to
the other very much.
Words in isolation or short phrases
might be mutually intelligible.
But when mixed in with different words
and when spoken at full speed,
it becomes much harder.
And just like with other pairs of
closely related languages,
speakers of Dutch and German often say
that they can understand the other
language much more in its written form
than in it's spoken form.
And like I said earlier in the video,
speakers of certain dialects might have
a much easier time understanding the
other language.
The question of the day for native
speakers of Dutch or German,
how well do you understand the other
language and if you've ever studied the
other language,
what was your experience like and for
other people after seeing the examples
in this video,
what's your impression of Dutch and
German?
Do they seem very similar to you?
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter and instagram.
And once again,
thank you to all of my patrion
supporters,
especially these amazing people right
here on the screen.
They are my top tier patrion supporters.
So many,
many special thanks to them.
And to everyone else.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.